[Music]
over the last three years researchers at
fermilab gathered around a 50-foot
particle accelerator controlled by
superconducting magnets
they shot high energy particles through
the race track looking to confirm a tiny
discrepancy between theory and
experiment
the object of interest was the muon
this year fermilab published the results
of the muon
experiment and the findings have
profound implications for new physics
this is the standard model of particle
physics
for the last 50 years it's been our best
description of the 17 known fundamental
particles and their interactions
muons are much like electrons with the
same electrical charge and spin
properties
but they're different in one important
way
they're 200 times heavier because of
this muons have more energy to briefly
emit and reabsorb hidden particles
they give us a special window into the
subatomic universe where unknown
particles could be lurking
each muon because of its spin properties
is generating its own little internal
magnetic field
and so when you take that muon and you
put it in an external magnetic field
like one you've generated in the
laboratory what that does is it changes
the frequency of their wobble ever so
slightly this is where we talk about a
quantity called the g factor of the muon
the g factor essentially tells you the
strength of that internal magnetic
moment that the muon has
so by determining very precisely how
that muon's internal magnetic moment is
interacting with the external magnetic
field we put it in in fact what we're
getting a
glimpse into is this quantum mechanical
world where all the other particles are
suddenly popping out for a moment in
time
the standard model predicts the muon's g
factor but when scientists measured it
20 years ago at the brookhaven national
laboratory they found a significant
statistical deviation which they call
3.7 sigma if you imagine flipping a coin
100 times that brookhaven result would
be about like finding 67 heads or 68
heads something like that and you think
wow
that's kind of weird i wonder if there's
something wrong with the coin the goal
with the neon g minus two experiment was
to follow up on this brookhaven
experiment and do the experiment again
at a laboratory capable of producing 20
times the number of muons
the results show an even more
significant deviation from the standard
model prediction
very close to the five sigma difference
needed to claim a scientific discovery
you would have to do the two experiments
40 000 times over before you would
expect to get a result as anomalous as
the one we see
from the two experiments at this point
and so the reason that
that is so exciting
is because it basically comes down to
two things
either
there's an 18th particle that we haven't
yet discovered directly
or there's something we don't understand
about the existing 17 particles and the
forces
that we know about that are interacting
with them
particles beyond the standard model
could help explain some of the most
enduring mysteries in physics such as
dark matter a substance we know exists
but haven't yet detected
but shortly after fermilab published its
results a group called bmw published
state-of-the-art supercomputer
calculations that target the dominant
source of error in the theory
the results bring the model's
predictions in line with the g minus two
measurements and that has other
implications for other calculations we
do in the standard model which makes
that that an interesting discovery in
and of itself
whether the muon g-2 experiment points
to an 18th particle or something we
don't understand about the existing
particles the results are not the last
word in particle physics
this is a perpetual motion machine the
most persistent dream of inventors has
been to get something for nothing in
short perpetual motion machines
the quest to design these machines has
captured the human imagination since the
middle ages
to build a perpetual motion machine
you'd have to evade the second law of
thermodynamics which says that in a
closed system entropy or disorder always
increases
this makes perpetual motion machines
impossible
but this year researchers at stanford
university and google made a profound
discovery they built a kind of perpetual
motion machine inside a quantum computer
this is a time crystal
it's a quantum object that forever
cycles between different states without
consuming energy
time crystals are an entirely new phase
of matter
the first to break a fundamental law of
symmetry in physics
in physics we often tend to think of
phases of matter and we tend to organize
our understanding of systems by
symmetries and their spontaneous
breaking okay so some of the most
fundamental symmetries that we know of
are translation symmetries in space and
translation symmetries in time so the
laws of physics should look the same
whether you do your experiment in this
location or you do your experiment today
and tomorrow and yesterday but there is
still this big difference between space
and time you can freely move back and
forth in space but we can't really move
back and forth in time
consider an ice crystal
its millions of atoms are arranged
periodically across space
this system is in equilibrium so its
properties won't change with time
time crystals on the other hand are
arranged periodically across space and
time
because they are both stable and ever
changing they don't respect time
translation symmetry
for a decade physicists have tried to
reconcile this with the laws of
thermodynamics
but it turns out they were approaching
it from the wrong angle
our entire understanding of phases of
matter of many body physics is based on
the laws of equilibrium thermodynamics
everything we know about quantum matter
is based on these fundamental laws
my collaborators and i were working in
this very different corner of physics
and we were thinking about phases of
quantum matter out of equilibrium this
is a class of systems that always remain
stuck in the state in which it started
and we were asking the question you know
what are the new kinds of possibilities
what are the new types of phases of
matter that are allowed we outline the
properties of one of the phases that we
found which we call the pi spin glass it
has a very
unique kind of spatial temporal order
and we had outlined those details in our
paper but hadn't made the connection
with with time crystals but then in the
course of our paper getting reviewed one
of the referees was like hey is this
you know is this phase a time crystal
and we were like yeah you're right it is
i think if he had set out to find a time
crystal we would have run into a lot of
the same objections that that various
people who were trying to create these
time crystals right into like in a lot
of physics you know a lot of things come
serendipitously
this year kamani collaborated with
google to create our time crystal in one
of the company's quantum computers
we've gone from asking what exists in
nature to what quantum mechanics allows
these new quantum computers are allowing
us to probe the full scope of what's
allowed by quantum mechanics time
crystals are just one very dramatic
example of how systems out of
equilibrium can display fundamentally
new types of physics there's so much
rich physics to be discovered here and
we've done so little
in the 1960s astronomers spotted a
mysterious ark towering above the milky
way
they called it the north polar spur and
assumed it was stellar debris in our
local galactic neighborhood
but a japanese astronomer had a
different theory
yoshiaki sufuwa thought the ark was just
a small part of a massive hidden
structure
a pair of bubbles at the galaxy's heart
for decades this was dismissed as a
fringe idea
there were a lot of papers explaining
why there is no sudden counterpart
like ever in in
science
people trying to explain what does not
exist
peter perdiel spent 25 years developing
the orbiting telescope erosita which
launched in 2019
last year e rosita conducted the first
large-scale survey of the sky in x-ray
and saw something astounding
there is a southern counterpart of that
what was known before the northern
bubble and we saw it with erosita
the japanese people they were the first
thinking about
this is probably something which is
connected to the galactic center the
milky way is like a pancake and we are
sitting in the pancake there are two
bubbles touching each other at the
center of this pancake and they are
filled with hot gas
these bubbles have a diameter of 50 000
light years and this is expanding these
bubbles and with the expansion one can
determine that the origin was about 15
or 20 million years ago
the culprit behind this ancient galactic
calamity may have been sagittarius a
star the supermassive black hole at the
center of our galaxy
today it's mostly quiet
but long ago
it could have consumed a hot cloud of
gas spewing energy in both directions
with the force of one hundred thousand
supernovas
with erosita and other telescopes
astronomers will continue to uncover the
enduring mysteries at the heart of the
universe and at the heart of our galaxy
[Music]
you